very special episode of happy airing  tomorrow Oh God okay I don't know if is  anyone watching the show happy on Sci Fi  okay it is it is the and I can say that  it's the most messed up show I've ever  been right a part of Chris Meloni plays  a corrupt cop who is now a hitman who I  play his daughter's imaginary friend who  is now who only he can see and is  dealing with but basically tomorrow  night and and I'm without any spoilers  but I my character sings a duet with an  Margaret effect while Chris Meloni  breaks the concrete penis off of a giant  naked man statue and it all it all is  crucial to the plot yeah all I will say  the part with the center's they keep  recycling the same oh yeah same oh happy  airs Wednesdays at 10:00 on sci-fi  Patton Oswalt thank you so much always  hilarious